[Music]
what's up guys we are back with another
cooking video finally I know you guys
been wanting cooking videos I think the
last cooking video is the jambalaya
video and that was over a year ago now
but we are back we are making salmon
today this specific recipe is my wife's
is favorite recipe that I make it's
healthy and it feels and looks a lot
fancier than it actually is it's very
simple to make very fast recipes I've
actually never bothered to name this
dish it's always been hey baby do you
want salmon 80 make salmon we've never
actually called it anything so now that
I'm here making the recipe video let's
just call it baked ginger salmon and
trust me fellas if you want to earn
brownie points with your lady friends
out there do yourself a favor make this
dish because this dish has earned me
major brownie points with my wife it's a
take notes so let's get started with our
marinade we're gonna start with hardest
fresh ingredients we're gonna have some
ginger some garlic and some green onions
the ginger I'm gonna cut it into
medallions me about like whoa run away
peace let's do six-month aliens so this
dish that we're making it does have an
Asian inspiration behind it hence the
use of ginger green onions is a very
popular Asian ingredients all right so
once you have her ginger nice it up
[Music]
alright then we got ourselves a bowl
here we're gonna just toss everything
we're cutting up into this bowl let's
move on to the garlic three cloves of
garlic we're gonna mince them just as
small nice we got that chopped up I
don't bring our garlic in a speaking of
Asian influence on this dish I noticed
that Asian foods have their own Holy
Trinity because in Cajun cooking there
is the Holy Trinity bell peppers onions
and celery for Chinese cooking
specifically I would say it's garlic
ginger and green onions let's go with
two spring onions chopped off that part
chop it and stack it alright once we got
that chopped up go ahead and add our
green onions in yeah my hands cool now
we got our fresh ingredients done moving
on to the liquids all right so our first
liquid will be sesame oil next it's in
the soy sauce
to add some pop for our marinade we're
gonna add some juice of the design and
finally we're gonna add some oyster
sauce one tablespoon of this for some
sweetness
we even balance it out with some of the
soy sauce and the lime juice
all right and let's go ahead and this is
what we got this is our marinade
concoction let's go ahead and whisk it
up real quick just get all the
ingredients worked in together
smells great mmm there we go we got our
marinade I've already washed the salmon
we're gonna section it off in portions
now the golden rule for making a portion
size for salmon it's the width of your
hand so if you can just put your hand
down this right here is the proper
portion size for salmon all right what
we're gonna do is put them back organize
them a bit - pie - there we go
and cactus little tails not worth much
but a hash throw it in here anyways
let's make room for the tail there we go
all right so now that we got our fish
cut up we're gonna season this real
quick with some salt and pepper
something very simple now be easy on the
salt just because we do have soy sauce
in the marinade and some pepper all
right with finally I'm just gonna spoon
on the marinade you want to just kind of
work it in I also forgot to mention that
you want to utilize a dish that you can
use to bake with you can dress it up and
then toss it right into the oven look at
that
so now we're gonna preheat our oven to
400 degrees Fahrenheit and we're gonna
bake all right so now after you've put
your foil on top to trap as much
moisture in we are now ready for the
oven 400 degrees here we come all right
so now with big salmon we want to bake
this for about 20 minutes
15 to 20 minutes now some people like to
eat them and slightly rare if you're
going for that slightly rare kind of
texture in your salmon
I would aim for 15 minutes but for me
because I don't trust the salmon it's
not sushi-grade I'm gonna go 20 minutes
I'm going for morbo or well-done but
with salmon you have to be very very
careful because you know easily overcook
it and when you do overcook salmon and
super dry it's almost as if you cook the
flavor out of it it doesn't taste as
good anymore so in the meantime while
our salmon is baking we're gonna work on
a little garnish that I like to put on
top all right so we're gonna take those
leftover green onions have about five of
them here and we're just gonna dice it
all up alright so once we have it all
diced up let's go ahead and toss it in
our Bowl alright and we're gonna just
season this with a little bit of salt
not too much salt goes a long way in
this
all right so next where you gonna start
the fire and then you want to put about
like three tablespoons of I don't know
actually about that much but yeah we
need some olive oil in here now the idea
here is then this is a trick that my mom
taught me when I was a kid we're gonna
want to keep this up until it starts
smoking a little bit and you're gonna be
able to see the smoke and once it gets
hot enough we're gonna take this and
pour right on top of that green onions
that we have over there I've never seen
this done and any other cuisines other
than Chinese cooking I don't know what
it's called the only thing I can call it
is flash cooking you know it's like
you're not really cooking these green
onions or simply pouring piping hot oil
on top of it and through that heat it's
gonna sizzle and that's it not too sure
you can actually see it in the camera
but I can see that my oil is already
smoking let's go ahead and bring in the
green onions and we got our hot oil
let's go ahead and just give this a nice
mix work in the green onions into the
heat try and use your chimichurri or
whatever you want to call it I don't
know I am done all right so now when
you're doing this green onion salsa
thing you're gonna want to be careful
when you're heating up the oil is I've
learned this from experience I let it
heat up for too long it's smoking about
thinking I maybe just give it a little
bit more just get that really really
piping hot next thing I know my entire
kitchens and golfed in flames not really
not the entire kitchen but the pan that
I'm heating the world on its engulfed in
flames and I'm freaking now a point is
the moment it starts smoking take it off
the burner so it doesn't get too hot and
actually ignites that's a scary moment
come on we've been waiting for one that
smells good that looks bomb
put this aside and let this rest so this
thing that's gonna be delicious it looks
perfect and it smells great in here
right now and add this little garnish on
top mmm out of this world but to further
complement this Emin we're gonna plate
it with some brown rice and some sauteed
spinach tonight and let's go ahead and
whip that up real quick and the oil to
your wok
and once it's hot enough we're gonna go
ahead and add some crushed ginger and
some crushed garlic and basically what
we want to do is just infuse this oil
with the flavors of garlic and ginger
it's optionally you can actually take
the garlic and ginger out but I'm gonna
keep it in here just because I want to
really get that flavor into this finish
[Music]
[Music]
all right so we're gonna have we start
off with a little bit of rice a little
pile in the middle
[Music]
very very garnishing BAM
let me got it there is one happy wife
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
half the taste test before the wife he
gets home
salmon is better Spanish good
[Music]